you might not guess it from the
silhouette but a mandalorian's armor is
as unique as their fingerprints
handed down through generations the
distinctive armor is a defining trait of
the mandalorian people and their culture
this is the history of mandalorian armor
explained
the mandalorians are a nomadic people
but they're not a species
anyone can be a mandalorian if they
practice the tenets of their faith
before the mandalorian boba fett was one
of the most well-known mandalorians in
the star wars universe
but although he wore mandalorian armor
he didn't really grow up in the culture
and therefore is not a true mandalorian
because mandalorians are a war-like
people who often act as mercenaries
wearing armor is one of the six actions
central to their identity
according to star wars novelist karen
travis the other five are speaking the
mandalorian language
contributing to the welfare of their
clan defending themselves and their
families
raising their children as mandalorians
and rallying around the sole leader of
their people
the mandalore when asked yet even though
their armor is a central part of their
culture
mandalorians like reminding each other
that what's inside matters most
a warrior is more than his armor is one
popular mandalorian
saying early mandalorian armor appeared
during season 2 of the animated series
star wars the clone wars
the episode the mandalore plot showed a
mural depicting
ancient mandalorian crusaders wearing
helmets over their cloaks
as they fought the jedi knights to
battle the forced powers of the jedi
the mandalorians modified their fighting
style and weaponry
clone wars director dave filoni once
told comicbook.com
the mandalorian jedi war that i have in
my mind is very much derived from the
oldest
style of thinking of mandalorians which
was that their weapons
their arsenal their technology had a
massive increase once they collided with
the jedi
and found these force-wielding people
that had abilities they didn't
understand
filoni continued their armor is a
reaction to the jedi
and i've always believed that because
that seemed to be something that would
be in the dna
of the joe johnston designs of them as
supercommandos
johnston who directed captain america
the first avenger and the rocketeer
was a concept artist on the original
star wars trilogy
incidentally filoni became the
showrunner on the animated series star
wars rebels
and is now a writer and director on the
mandalorian
both star wars the clone wars and star
wars rebels delve
into other mandalorian armor history
tied to the mandalorian civil war
which split the group into the pacifist
new mandalorians
and the militant death watch although
many fans would recognize a mandalorian
by their armor
specifically the full-face helmet with
t-shaped visor
this schism revealed other variations
particularly in the helmets
for instance the female warriors of
death watch known as the night owls
wore helmets with eye slits that would
tilt up like an owls
sabine wren the star wars rebels
character who is a mandalorian warrior
and demolitions expert has a night owls
helmet that she inherited
speaking of sabine she doesn't follow
the strict helmet rules that denjarin
outlines on the mandalorian
namely that he can't remove his helmet
in front of other people or his vow is
broken and he's no longer part of his
tribe
sabine often goes without her helmet
even though she usually wears her armor
a mandalorian's armor includes a lot of
accessories
the helmet for instance has a comb link
with an antenna it also includes night
vision
a tactical display facial and vocal
recognition
a fingerprint scanner video recording
links to vehicles and weapons
and flight controls for the jet packs
that mandalorians use to be more
maneuverable in battle
in the mandalorian den jaren receives a
jet pack from the armorer at the end of
season 1
which he uses to fight against moth
gideon mando fares pretty well
considering that he's still learning the
controls unlike the undignified
trajectory of boba fett
in star wars return of the jedi one key
part of the mandalorians arsenal is the
van brace
a wrist gauntlet chock full of various
weaponry
including a 25 meter long retractable
fiber cord
flamethrower energy shield protector
trackers
laser targeting sights launchers for
tranquilizing or explosive darts
a mini rocket launcher motion detectors
repulsors
a communication system and a touchscreen
display next to its well-known
silhouette mandalorian armor is
also known for its toughness thanks to
best car a material that's also
called mandalorian iron or mandalorian
steel
vescar protects against blaster shots as
well as lightsaber strikes but it's also
lightweight
allowing the wearers to be much more
agile than say tony stark learning to
fly in his mark 1 suit in 2008's iron
man
okay this is where i don't want to be
yikes bheskar has such remarkable
strength because of both its natural
properties
and mandalorian metalworking techniques
dinjarin causes a stir when a client
pays him in bars of vesgar
another mandalorian remembers how the
rare metal could be mined
only on their home planet of mandalore
and was likely stolen during the great
purge
in the mandalorian's first episode the
armorer uses a bar of best guard to
forge a new pauldron
or shoulder plate fermando the colors
and markings on mandalorian armor can be
highly varied and are often used to
express lineage or state of mind
according to travis that said
mandalorians also decorate their armor
according to taste
they'll repaint their armor if they
change clans or if they're on a
particular task
sabine wren for instance often changed
her armor's markings much like she
changed her hair color
adding a prominent insignia in her
starboard design a precursor to the
emblem of the rebel alliance
blue and green are popular armor colors
for mandalorians who like to be
conspicuous
travis wrote referencing another
mandalorian saying it's one thing to see
us coming
and another to do something about it
mandalorian armor doesn't just provide
protection
it's also an heirloom because bhaskar
can last for hundreds of years
as sabine wren once said the armor i
wear
is 500 years old i reforged it to my
liking but the battles
the history the blood all lives within
it and the same goes for every
mandalorian
travis explained in star wars insider
that as a nomadic people mandalorians
frugally invested much of their wealth
into their armor and weapons
this was certainly practical because
they could take their earnings with them
early in the mandalorian mando receives
a large payment of besgar
after delivering the child to the
mysterious imperial client
after mando presents the best guard to
the armorer she suggests that she can
craft a full queer rasp for him
plus whistling birds a type of mini
missile the excess he donates to the
foundlings
the orphaned children the mandalorians
protect catching up afterward with grief
karga head of the bounty hunter's guild
mando draws
several stairs over his shiny new
threads but he's really just following
the investment strategy of ancient
mandalorians
besides cargo notes the grumblers are
just jealous that they didn't get all
that loot
mandalorians love personalized armor
sabine wren
embraced this part of mandalorian
culture throughout star wars rebels
and not just through her signature
design rebels fans know that she kept
the armor's insulating body glove but
stripped away a lot of the other pieces
for maximum mobility
she also upgraded her helmet's
electronics although she used the video
and image recording abilities to capture
her artwork much more than the targeting
viewfinder
on the mandalorian the armorer has
strikingly distinctive armor
from the fur across the back plate to
the shape of her eyes on her helmet
polygon notes that her helmet also
appears to have
zebrak horns which could be a reference
to darth maul
a zabrak who briefly ruled mandalore and
headed the death watch on star wars the
clone wars
mandalorian armor often has sigils or
symbols painted on the chest plate or
helmet indicating their lineage
allegiance or even awards for bravery
according to travis
the armor can also have a signet
specifying the wearer's particular clan
when the mandalorian begins din jaren
has no signet
even though he was adopted by the
mandalorians as an orphan
was trained as a warrior and joined
their tribe he starts the first season
as a classic western lone wolf archetype
that changes once he meets the child who
uses his
force powers to help den defeat a
charging mudhorn a creature that
resembles a gigantic rhino
when the armorer suggests that he has
earned the mudhorn as a signet for
failing the creature he declines
saying that it wasn't a noble kill but
once den has a change of heart and
retrieves the child from the imperials
who want his power
the armorer decides that den is worthy
of such an honor
she forges a mudhorn signet for him and
instructs him to take care of the green
foundling and to return the child to his
own
kind if possible in the meantime she
says
you are a clan of two check out one of
our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about star wars
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]